I want you to meet James class.
He's a college student from Midland Park,
New Jersey.
He's currently the vice
president of his college Republican Club.
He said he's currently
supporting the V.A.. I'm swimming.
James, welcome.
What college? By the college.
I'm sure
you've made it clear
you do not believe that the 2020 election
was rigged against former
President Trump.
What is your message?
To the people in the Republican Party
that still believe
the election was stolen?
Well,
my my message to them
is just show me the evidence.
It's the same thing.
That I said to Donald Trump
in the aftermath of the 20, 20 election
was show me the evidence.
If I see the evidence,
I'm happy to support
fighting all the way to the U.S.
Supreme Court and beyond.
But there's no evidence.
And so I'm sorry.
All these conspiracy theories,
you know, he still talks about,
oh, they're bringing boxes of ballots
into, you know, Fulton County, Georgia.
No matter how many times
we explain to him
if that's the way they do it,
the ballots
get collected at the local places
in full county
and then the boxes get brought to
the central place to be counted.
So, of course, all night
boxes of ballots are being brought in.
But people see little clips
on the Internet of video ever.
And he's saying it to me,
this is the most destructive thing
he's done.
People want to believe the president,
United States. Right.
And even when it's a president
that I don't agree with,
it's Jason. Right.
James. Sorry, James.
James, even when it's a president
we don't agree with,
if it's something really important,
we want to believe them
because we also want to believe
that they know stuff that we don't know.
And so if they're telling us something
and that's
when it was over for me with Donald
when he stood behind the seal,
the president
in the East Room of the White House
at two 30 in the morning
on election morning and said
the election was stolen.
Now, let me tell you something,
everybody.
If it had been, which it wasn't,
he'd have no damn idea at that point.
Although voted him in counted yet.
Governor Chris,
let me
actually just play that moment,
because you've talked about this moment
as being the critical moment for you.
And I want to
play it to remind our viewers
this is a fraud on the American public.
This is an embarrassment to our country.
We were getting ready to win
this election.
Frankly, we did win this election.
It's it's a very sad
it's a very sad moment.
To me, this is a very sad moment.
And we will win this.
And as far as I'm concerned,
we already have won.
So that was the East Room
of the White House.
What about that
moment changed it for you?
All right. Look
how many
how many people out here, our parents.
Can you raise your hand
all right.
Look,
that's like
when your kid comes home
from school with a bad grade
and you're like, well,
how did this happen?
The teacher's unfair.
The test was rigged.
It was none of the stuff
that she told us to study.
And and and and the guy next to me
was talking the entire time
and distracting me.
And that's why I did bad on the test.
That is a child
it's a child.
That's a child's reaction.
Everybody
every parent out there
recognizes it, knows it.
We were about to win what?
You were winning for a time in certain
states. Why?
Because some states counted
the machine votes first.
And those generally tended to be
for Republicans.
Other states like Ohio,
he was losing in the beginning.
He's not complaining
about the Ohio result, though, is he?
He was losing for 4 hours in Ohio
because they counted the mail-in
ballots first.
Then they count the machine ballots.
And he won Ohio by like eight points.
It's a child's reaction.
And I just I beg you to think about this
Don't allow the showmanship
to obscure the facts.
The facts are he lost to Joe Biden
and he lost to Joe Biden,
in my opinion,
because he lost independent voters
and he lost independent voters
because they took a chance on him in 2016
because they didn't like Hillary Clinton.
I'm all for that.
But guess what?
They wanted to see performance
Say one quick story, Anderson.
Mary Pat
and I sat with him on Valentine's Day.
20, 17
and had lunch with him
in the dining room
off of the Oval Office.
And he said to me,
What's your political advice for me?
And I said, Mr.
President, you didn't win the election.
She lost it.
She blew it.
But it doesn't matter,
because look where we're sitting.
You're the president.
So now
make the next four years
about the country.
And if you make the next four years
about the country,
you're going to get reelected in
a landslide.
Make it about them, not about you.
And if you do that, you're going to win.
And he looked at me
and you'll remember this.
He shook his head.
He goes.
Chris, you worry too much.
I think I was worried just enough.
I want you to meet Christine.
Gloria.
She's a student
at Harvard Law School,
work in New York City.
She's a Republican
and says she's currently
supporting Governor DeSantis.
Christie, welcome.
Hi, Governor Christie. Hey there.
My question, is President
Trump significantly
increased tariffs on Chinese goods?
President Biden has mostly kept
these tariffs in place.
Would you reduce, maintain
or increase tariffs on China
if you were elected president?
I would make it part
of an overall negotiation
to reset our relationship with China.
We need
to make the Chinese understand
that, like the party's over.
For the last 50 years,
we have been investing in China
to try to bring them
into the community of nations
and to try to make them better
because we thought
it would make us better, too.
And in some ways it has.
We have great trade with China
over a long period of time, and by great
I mean a large volume of it.
But the Chinese have taken advantage
of our good nature
Stealing our intellectual property,
spying on us,
causing trouble around the world.
Unfair trade deals
and it's time for them to stop now.
They're no longer a fledgling economy.
The second
largest economy in the world
and inching up on us.
And so what I would do on
tariffs would be to say, look,
they don't like those tariffs.
And those tariffs also increase
prices for some of us. Right.
But we're not
going to
get rid of that stuff
until they decide to be fair
on those other things.
You come up with a great idea.
Intellectual property.
You should be able to own that.
And if they want to use it,
they pay you for it.
That's stealing from you.
Tick tock is here in this country.
We let them in.
Facebook and Twitter are not in China.
They want Facebook.
They're going to get Facebook, Twitter
and our social media into China.
On the tick tock.
Say they don't tick tock goes
the Christie administration.
They need to understand
that we will be fair,
but we won't be chumps.
And so I don't want to give that away.
On the CNN town hall in June of 2023,
I want to use it
as a card
that we can negotiate
with going forward smartly.
So that we we write this relationship
because if we don't
write this relationship,
it will be the relationship
that defines
the world for the next 50 years.
And I'd rather have to have that
be a prosperous,
fair, competitive relationship
rather than a relationship
that involves warfare.